oh I'm dan Wattenberg as you may have
noticed men look different from women
but do men and women think differently
if so could these differences be
hardwired in our genes and in our brains
what would that mean for women what
would that mean for men joining us to
sort through the conflict and the
consensus are Deborah Tannen professor
of linguistics at Georgetown University
and author of you just don't understand
women and men in conversation and
talking from 9:00 to 5:00 Robert Wright
of the New Republic magazine and author
of the moral animal why we are the way
we are the new science of evolutionary
psychology Lawrence hedges professor of
social science and education at the
University of Chicago and co-author of a
major new study on gender differences
and Christina Sommers professor of
philosophy at Clark University and
author of who stole feminism how women
have betrayed women the topic before
this house is how different are men and
women this week on think-tank
[Music]
boys are made of frogs and snails and
puppy-dog tails and girls girls are made
of sugar and spice and all that's nice
you know for more than a quarter of a
century the women's movement has been
chipping away at stereotypes like those
in America now the economic political
and professional imbalances between men
and women are closing fast
but the evidence behind some of those
stereotypes is mounting
recent studies reveal that men and women
use different parts of their brains for
language girls are nearly twice as good
as boys on many word choice tests and
girls are far more likely to be top
scorers on writing tests boys are seven
times more likely than girls to score in
the top 5% on science tests and twice as
likely to score high on math tests what
about the mating game according to a
survey of 37 cultures men tend to value
physical attractiveness and youth when
choosing a partner while women are more
concerned about status ambition and
resources what happens when social
barriers to women fall since 1960 the
share of women receiving medical degrees
has increased Sevenfold while the number
receiving law degrees has jumped 17 fold
today the majority of college students
are women who on the average receive
better grades than their male
counterparts
a few months ago Speaker Newt Gingrich
declared that men are biologically
driven to hunt and kill giraffes and
that women were biologically unsuited to
fighting in the trenches let's just go
around the room one starting with you
Deborah Tannen how different are men and
women the difference is that I'm
interested in our differences in ways of
speaking ways of using language in
everyday life there seems to be a
tendency and all of these are just
tendencies they're never absolute
differences tendency for women to focus
more on the connection versus distance
dimension
meant to be somewhat more attuned
through whether a way of speaking is
going to put them in a one down position
and many other differences we can talk
about ways of valuing the role of
conversation in a relationship ways of
using language to accomplish your goals
in everyday interaction
Larry hedges you just authored
co-authored a a new study on this matter
yes and the differences that we looked
at were differences in intellectual
functioning and their the short summary
is that on the average men and women are
not that different in their intellectual
functioning with a few various very
stereotyped exceptions but in spite of
the fact that they aren't that different
on the average men tend to outnumber
women substantially at both the top end
of the distribution that is among very
talented individuals and also at the
bottom end among the anti talented
individuals if you like okay Bob right
well from the standpoint of evolutionary
psychology
I guess the sex difference that most
certainly has a genetic basis is in the
realm of sex or romance the for example
men are less discriminating about sex
partners in some sense more more
polygamous on average at least than
women but this the same logic that leads
to that conclusion does extend to the
question of aggressiveness although I
don't buy newt gingrich's explanation of
exactly why that is an evolutionary term
you are permitted by your magazine to
agree with Newt Gingrich periodically
this was the one this fulfills my yearly
quota okay the and and and this issue of
aggression may in turn extend into
realms beyond physical combat so that so
that that men for example Deborah's work
suggests that they're more combat in
conversation and and lost exactly okay
Christina summers yes I think the
differences can be exaggerated I do not
think that women think differently from
men I completely disagree with my
colleagues in feminist philosophy who
believe there is a special female
epistemology of female logic that seems
to me to be a nonsense however I do
think there are rather strong
differences in preferences between men
and women not
romantically speaking and even in in the
areas and in employment women gravitate
towards jobs that seem to engage them
more emotionally you're going to always
have probably more women as kindergarten
teachers than helicopter repair you know
servicemen I often wonder why we are so
obsessed with picking apart exactly how
much is social and exactly how much is
well kinetic or some combination of both
no right but I to answer your question
as to why we are so obsessed about it
because starting in the 1960s a very
prominent group of women said there
really were no differences these were
all socially imposed upon women and they
were harming women so I mean I think
that's the answer that we're in the why
we're in this argument and that in
itself is kind of interesting after I
frequently amassed after I speak are
these differences you described
biological or cultural and I often find
that people who ask me think they know
they either are convinced it's all
biological or they're convinced it's all
cultural and they tend to pattern by
gender it's usually the women who feel
it's all cultural and the men who asked
me and have already decided that they
think it's all biological that in itself
to me it's an interesting cultural
phenomenon I suspect that the women are
thinking if we can say that there are
really no difference is it's all
cultural then we can change everything
we don't like about the world tomorrow
and on the other side the feeling themes
maybe if it's all biological then a few
women are in a subordinate position in
the world it's your own fault we can't
do anything about it and don't blame me
and I think in fact neither of those is
true cultural training is very hard to
change and biological training is very
possible to change me what's more human
than to go against our biological Givens
Bob right where does the evolutionary
psychologist come out on this well
certainly certainly not with the view
that that genes are destiny but on the
other hand with the view that there are
some inclinations which are are fairly
stubborn and that they will never be
entirely defeated and you know you asked
why does it matter to what extent this
is deeply biological
you know one example is I think for a
while 20 years ago or so there was the
idea that you could have a sexual
morality that was that was premise taun
the idea that that men and women are
identical in the way they think about
sex in the way they react to sex and
that had a lot of effects I actually
think one of the effects it had was to
alleviate to free males from a kind of
moral responsibility they'd previously
been told they had a kind of
considerateness they had to extend to
someone for example in realizing that
sex might mean less to the male then to
the female and they should keep that in
mind and you know I think on the one
hand you know if males are aware of this
they can certainly you know we can all
control ourselves on the other hand
there are some basic features of human
nature that that exist in cultures
everywhere and are reflected in in the
in the moral systems that evolve
culturally and and I think you know
robust moral system has to take into
account basic differences that are that
are gonna be there to some extent or
another don't you think that may be a
mistake that some feminists made if
there are these differences between men
and women and and I think of bedrock
differences that men are stronger than
women men can harm women and there may
have been a reason why we evolved
certain customs and codes of civility
their children and their children but
codes of gallantry as showing gestures
of gestures gestures of respect towards
women those may have been very very
important to protect women not to demean
women it's them though there were
demeaning aspects for sure but I think
as feminists perhaps we were too hasty
to disparage these customs and mores
that served a very important purpose of
protecting women yet I would be worried
if we jumped too hastily to the
conclusion that the differences that we
observe between men and women are
necessarily biologically based and
immutable that would freeze into place
certain differences in the opportunity
structure for
in society that we might not want to
freeze into place well but I mean now
you're talking like a politician you're
supposed to be a social scientist which
is we do not regard that as an oxymoron
that now said so you shouldn't say what
should be but what is now what what does
your study show I mean are there
immutable differences I mean men do not
bear children that is a major difference
in in the human beings life let's say
and don't usually play the premier role
in in rearing them and nurturing them
that is another premier difference in
the lives of men and women I mean can
you then just say sort of politically
well we should ignore that I'm not
suggesting we should ignore that but
what I am suggesting is that when we
observe differences that are as large as
the ones we found in our study
differences of two to one or seven to
one in some cases those kinds of
differences could be used to suggest
that it's all right
if scientist in science men outnumber
women seven to one and it's not a
difference that we should really worry
about we should we shouldn't ask
ourselves the question could this be
because there are more opportunities for
men and more encouragement to go into
science for men there's a danger that
obvious differences for example women
can give birth some women can give birth
to babies and no man can obviously not
all women too can be misinterpreted for
example one of the early arguments
against women receiving higher education
was that all that blood supply that was
going to be going to their brains when
they did all this difficult intellectual
work would be taken from the womb and
would affect their childbearing
capacities so the it the question is
still open what are the impacts of these
various differences and you know I think
they can be over interpreted but I think
the important thing is that we must
believe in equality of opportunity if a
little girl is math prodigy then every
you know the classes should be available
to her she should be able to pursue her
her talent unfortunately what's
happening right now is many women's
groups in particular the American
Association of University Women and a
group called fair test have said aha
girls are not scoring the same
boys on the SAT and on the napes we have
to change the test National Assessment
of Educational Progress and the girls
are behind in math and science
therefore it is sexism at work and
they're actually changing SAT tests now
in ways which to favor the girls and
there's the suggestion that they should
take away time limits or they shouldn't
reward boys for guessing now this is
ridiculous it's part of intelligence to
make educated guesses and to the
quick-witted and it just seems to me to
be all wrong we're going it's the
dumbing down this is a very it seems to
me this is a very dangerous phenomenon
because it leads to the idea of
redefining the criterion not just for
men and women but for any groups that
happen to be important in the society
and I think that's a serious mistake of
shooting the messenger rather than
trying to find out what we can learn
from the message you know I wanted to
say that um you wanted to be kind of
agnostic on the basis of cognitive
differences between men and women and
that's actually true that's from the
point of view of evolutionary psychology
there aren't really clear reasons to
predict a very specific cognitive
differences that's not to say they don't
have an evolutionary basis but but what
you can what is more what is fairly
likely is that in the realm of what you
might call ambition there is some
difference between the average man and
the average woman and that's the kind of
thing that could have killed the
difference who is more ambitious oh man
and in Deborah's work uuuu I mean men
men men are bigger or bigger show-offs
and there's a fairly clear-cut
evolutionary reason for this and another
related thing from an evolutionary
standpoint is there's there's some
reason to believe that parents may have
an innate inclination to push boys
harder because during evolution the
social status of a son paid off and
reproduced in reproductive terms more
than the social status of a daughter now
that doesn't mean that that parents are
condemned to do this for eternity in
fact in my own experience I have two
daughters being aware of this tendency
if anything makes me makes me actually
want to combat it I mean you know you
can give the daughter a fair shake and
and to the extent that parents do that
then any difference in your findings for
example that's new to see
it's pushing the mail possible better
men and women are equally ambitious but
for different goals man they want to be
the football star or the CEO and a woman
may be extremely ambitious I mean to go
back a year or so may be extremely
ambitious to raise three children really
well and have a home and a family and do
things that you know are in my judgment
more important than about 99 percent of
the the other kind of jobs oh and things
that are even less obviously related to
to to kind of being a mother but but
certainly yes my guess would be based on
evolutionary psychology that that in the
realm of kind of being you know being
out there and and and and and and
seeking respect another another
difference you find is that men want
respect and women want women to want
people to like them at least on average
in terms of percentages and exactly I
mean all of these are statistical
differences but in that realm you you
would expect you would expect a
difference in that direction surprising
though if you look at Department of
Education data more girls are going to
college than boys and they ask were you
encouraged to go they ask counselors
were you encouraged by a teacher a
counselor a parent and far more girls
claim to have been encouraged so there
may be something amiss in our society
right now as I'm a mother of two boys so
I'm the boy's advocate here but I really
feel that we are not encouraging our
boys as much as our girls now that boys
are getting left behind and there's a I
know a great deal of hype about the
shortchange silenced girls but if you
actually look who's getting the better
grades it's the girls who's in most of
the honors clubs in the service clubs in
the school newspaper its girls are over
represented the one area where boys are
over-represented is sports and their
feminine are going after that with a
vengeance who gets in more trouble with
with drugs and drugs and alcohol and
delinquency dropping out it's boys are
over represented in those areas but the
finding that that women that girls get
better grades than boys is an old
finding and it goes way back to a time I
think before the feminists arrived
and has persisted to this day in every
area better study habits or greater task
persistence who knows well in a
difference but it is also possible well
it doesn't mean you you pull all the
findings of the white girls fail stuff
and true all of them knows you can pick
out lots of them that that I think have
been misinterpreted but there's a lot of
stuff there I think that's very real
like that well for example the findings
that girls are called on less in class
no now look at the latest research Gerry
Brophy at Michigan State and Jacqueline
Echols it's really a myth well I work in
the research I've read let's try what do
they say and then you tell me what is no
counter-argument at Michigan State says
that the he's simply boys are get more
attention because it's negative
attention they are disciplined more and
if you're sitting there observing you
will see Johnny what do you think is the
capital of New York it's a form of
classroom management so boys get what's
important according to Brophy and others
is the quality of the interaction and
their boys are not getting more
qualitative research sure the research
findings of the sad curse I'm sure
they've done in their their book called
failing at fairness I mean what a
research journal where has their data a
and peer-reviewed it hasn't there I've
read their research and many others too
that's what everyone thinks that there
are many others that are not there well
I believe they're there I mean it's not
my immediate feel but let me just say
the kind of thing that they find is that
if a boy asks a question the teacher is
more likely to ask him a challenging
question more likely to follow up with
questions the challenge and I observe
this in my own classrooms girls in my
women young women in my own classrooms I
have classes of women and men I've done
my own Studies on this too I will often
have three four or five young women in
the classroom never speak in class I
very rarely have young men in the class
that never speak in class women tell me
that if they speak in class one day they
try to be quiet the next because this is
not in elementary or secondary school at
least the vast majority of the teachers
are women so if there is a
discriminatory act going on it is women
on women right well that's very
interesting because I think definitely a
lot of the expectations that we have
which we voiced on others in other words
you expect a woman to be a certain way
you expect a man to be a certain way
it's equally true of women and as it is
of men there's no reason that it
shouldn't be let me ask you a question
as a as a social scientist how much of
the social science in America today is
pre driven that in other words somebody
is going in there with a liberal view or
a conservative view and saying here's
what I'm looking to prove and we all
know you can jiggle a lot of these
studies and how much of it is the
equivalent of a man or a woman in a
white coat in a medical lab you know
checking everything one against another
are the social sciences ideologically
driven to some extent of course they are
and they have to be because they're you
know they're it is social science but
many of the large data collection
programs that are multi-purpose data
collection programs are so large
involved involve so many different
scientists and have to be vetted by so
many different interests that in fact
and I suspect many of those special
interests and special perspectives kind
of cancel one another out it so far as
what we've been talking about what
should we do about education let's go
this started with you Bob right and come
around this way well I mean the policy
prescription that's clear to me and has
some relevance to education is that if
affirmative action for the for the sexes
is to be based on the assumption that
the sexes are identical in nature so
that any imbalance in the representation
of males and females in a given
workforce or at a given level is assumed
to be due to discrimination that is
surely a faulty assumption I really
think from the point of evolutionary
psychology you can say that on the other
hand the evolutionary psychology
provides you reasons why an enlightened
boss might in some cases in a sense
systematically favor women over men
it suggests that that men are more
likely to be egotistical in their in
their pursuit of career advancement and
even sacrifice the interests of the
organization they're working for to
their own personal interests
then women are this is not a hundred
percent certain finding with this very
good reason to believe it so I think you
know in policy terms this can in some
senses cut against women in some senses
cut in some senses favor them Linares
Bob Wright has expanded the topic from
education to education and affirmative
action now where would you what should
we be doing that we're not doing given
that we don't know that the differences
are entirely biological I think we
should try to do more to equalize
opportunity structures for men and women
in education first of all in the long
and that would mean for example working
harder with boys to become better
writers as one of the prime examples
right as well as as well as it comes
that are mathematicians exactly but in
the show I would like to add that in the
short run the imbalance of very talented
individuals that is the fact there are
more very talented men than women in
areas like mathematics and science has
real implications for trying to achieve
a closer to a balance of representation
of the genders and Sciences means that
we either have to accept lower goals or
recruit harder to get more women into
the sciences Deborah Tannen I agree with
what Barbour I said earlier that if
there are differences it's in
everybody's interests interest to
understand what they are and move on
from there
I think that for work situations as well
as classroom situations and home
relationships if we can see patterns and
identify them we can equalize
opportunity by taking them into account
an example that has come up there's very
good evidence that men are more likely
than women to be aggressive and to use
open argumentation and this could also
be cultural because it may not be true
of Japanese and other cultures but in
the Western society the open exchange of
argument as a way of learning things is
much more congenial to the men than the
women and this could be one reason that
many women back off in a classroom that
has taught that way there's a fair
amount of evidence that women often drop
out of science classes because they
don't like that argumentative classroom
atmosphere and they're uncomfortable
with it well that's a way you could
start out not lowering the requirements
for how much a scientist has to know to
get
by no means but creating an environment
that women might be more comfortable
getting the scientific training and
might not drop out Christina I think
except one thing that's very important
is a lot of the research on gender in
the last 10 or 15 years has been done by
feminist advocates who are committed to
assertive ICTA Memon ism and the
research cannot be trusted they
exaggerate women's vulnerability they
exaggerate women's oppression and I hope
that politicians and journalists will be
careful to get to the worst more
balanced scholars because I think in
education we're not getting a good
accurate picture I think when it comes
to gender bias in the workplace we're
not getting an accurate picture we have
to get to the as I said to the more
solid research okay thank you Christina
Sommers Lawrence hedges Robert Wright
and Deborah Tannen thank you please send
your comments and questions to New River
media one one-five-zero 17th Street
Northwest Washington DC 2 0 0 3 6 we can
also be reached via email at think-tank
at pbs.org or on the world wide web at
www.flairsgymnastics.com
for think-tank the father of three
daughters and one son I am and
Wattenberg
[Music]
this has been a production of BJ W
incorporated in association with New
River media which are solely responsible
for its content